hi my name is Jo and I can't grow beard
hi joining us Jill I know it's tough
these days showing your face in public
without any hair on it you're very brave
who must go first all my friends can
grow beards and they make fun of me
relentlessly and and they'll ask me
they'll say hey did you did you just
shave no no I didn't I haven't shaved in
a week this is what I got you think
that's bad
I've been growing this thing out for
over a year I look 40 yesterday I caught
my girlfriend reading an article called
the 31 hottest bearded man of all time
how about those articles that are like
check out this ugly guy who suddenly got
really hot when he grew a beard you guys
see that 50 shades of grey trailer
everybody's complaining because the main
guy had to shave for the role and all of
a sudden he's not attractive what the
he's so hot he's a male model actor I
mean like one fell super the razor isn't
a chance of that that he's hot it is
hairless discrimination is what I saw
last November oh no it's November
November this is a safe place
we don't acclimate to an impossible male
beauty standards love that yes last
November people were asking me Oh when
you're gonna grow it out you're gonna
grow it out and you know Matt that made
me feel like less of a man right yes
hard but you just have to donate to
charity without taking photos of your
sweet mustache we don't need to hide
behind follicular lives oh yeah at least
we're honest about our Jolla friends are
cyclical right we could shave it becomes
minority well psychologically be tragic
you and me and all of us again
and repeat after me I am a man the beard
struck the head yeah very weird letter
we are your beer